- This is random and I
know you don't remember,
you should not remember this,
it was a nothing moment.
When I first moved out
here after high school,
I lived with a girl that
wanted to be an actor.
She was like, we needed money.
You know, 'cause you only
get so many singing things
and I didn't want to be an
actor, I wanted to be a singer.
And (laughs)
and she was like, "You
should come do extra work."
And my very first job you were directing
the episode of Sabrina, the Teenage Witch.
- I remember it really well.
- [Kelly] You do not.
- Yes, I do and I'll tell you why.
Your girlfriend was on the show.
- [Kelly] She was.
- You were just standing there
visiting her, supporting her.
- I was an extra but I
was just standing there
because I didn't know what
I was supposed to be doing.
- And I want to tell you that your energy
was so palpable that I
literally went to the producer
and I said, "We have to use
this young woman in some way."
And you got to wink.
- I winked and I went, I
went like this to Sabrina
and I pissed off so many people that day.
Because all those people that were there,
you know, the extras wanted to be actors.
And they all knew I didn't.
And you were like, "Hey
we need you to do this."
And I was like, "I'm
just pissing everyone off
"over here on the left."
But I found out I got paid more
so I was like, "I will
do whatever you want."